[Music]
well it's that time of the year it's the
end of the year it's my solo episode and
I couldn't think of what I wanted to do
like last year I did a health update
I've done like top 20 lessons in 2020 so
there was always something that felt
really like top of Mind pertinent and
this year I just didn't have that thing
I just didn't have that one thing that
felt like this is what I want to talk
about so
it hit me literally yesterday as I'm
recording this today
um that I should ask you guys what you
want to know about me and so this is a q
a so this is like an AMA q a kind of
style solo episode and I hope you enjoy
it I hopefully I've done a good enough
job scanning the comments to find a
variety of questions we're going to
start with health update and we're going
to end with the best lesson in 2022
which kind of encompasses what I you
know the topics that I would usually
cover on a given year so Health Journey
update so some of you maybe know maybe
don't know I uh I had a breast explant
in April end of April of this year 2022
and
um you know I have been on such a
journey since really uh the very the
beginning of 2021 with uh hormones
um weight fluctuation really just going
up
um with
um you know just energy levels to some
degree
um yeah lots of biomarkers through all
those sort of experience like lessons
and testing that I've done so many blood
tests like I think I've actually reached
the point in time that I'm not scared of
needles which is really saying something
because when I was young I used to pass
out those updates like last year's
update will give you a really good sort
of grasp as a lot of those things but
explant played a really big role and
I've I was I had such a big impact on me
within hours I decided to share it and
nobody even knew for sure that I had
implants and so I got them back when I
was 32 uh so like it's about eight years
ago about is when I got them and so I
had them in for seven and a half years
and really I just started to notice
things like my weight was increasing my
hair wasn't as healthy you can see it's
kind of getting longer finally
um but I cut it because it wasn't just
wasn't healthy anymore that was part of
my reason for cutting it
um so just there was just lots of lots
of things and so as soon as I had them
out that night I could feel like natural
oils on my skin for the first time which
is probably why my skin and my scalp
were so dry for a couple years
um and I mean I tried everything to like
solve my scalp issues like felt gross
but it just was what it was and
um and then the next morning I had so
much energy so I posted about it and it
became thing and my doctor and I went on
Good Morning America like six days after
surgery and he was really
um nervous to watch me like going like
this with my arms and like going behind
my back but he did a great job and he
really supported it and has seen it
before in fact when I was in his office
he was like
um
you know
I think this is really going to help you
and I'm saying that because I've just
seen it too many times so I appreciate
that because I I have since heard from
so many women that what does it take to
get your doctor to like believe you and
that's a part of it so because it's easy
to talk you out of it because again
there's no like exact it's not like you
can go do a test and test positive for
breast implant illness so it's been a
journey since then it's been up and down
I've you know I've found out since um
then that I also have mold like three
different strains of mold and my
hormones are like tough to come back I
mean especially like thyroid is really
just like not seeming to sort of get
where it needs to get some of my
hormones are coming back for sure heavy
metals which were discovered last year
were super super high so those are
coming down as well and so I you know
one of the latest things that I have
been doing I'm just about to go in for
my second round of it is um something
called Ebu and no I don't know what that
stands for but it basically is like a
blood die analysis with ozone so they
have one of one line and one arm and
another and the other and it come it's a
closed system it pulls you end up
filtering half of your blood it goes
through a machine it goes through ozone
which ozone is a stressor to the body
but it also is um you know there are
positive stressors so they monitor just
how much ozone you get based on the
color of your blood and for me it was I
only got 30 minutes in to the 60 and my
blood was all way too dark that's a sign
of oxidative stress so they stop the
ozone anyway continue to filter the
blood and there was tons of plaque and
various different things in the filter
which in the future they say that
they're going to be able to
um uh maybe be able to do analysis on
that just to see what is coming out of
the blood into the filter but for this
time being it's just um witnessing sort
of what's in it
um and um and then it goes back into and
then it gets clean and ozone back into
you again so I did that I actually had a
pretty horrible reaction I had a really
really big histamine reaction where I
um they I I basically felt super tired
for two days and then I lost my voice
and then I had a lot of congestion so
that can happen as sort of a mast cell
reaction to
um uh the ozone and how much stress was
put on the body so
um so I'm going in for round two but
like with quercetin before and
glutathione after and NAC before I go in
um and pepcid's supposed to help so
anyway we've got a new protocol but um
I'll keep you guys updated on how the
Ebu ends up working over the course of
time
um and
honestly just doing less
like
I've pushed so hard like I just I do I
push so hard I I was doing all the
things I I hit a breaking point and I
October and uh I like broke down crying
I went to Chicago I went to go watch my
friend Aaron run the Chicago marathon
and my sister and I were there and um I
remember holding this like packet of
pills that I was supposed to take and I
just said a broke I couldn't like open
it and I was like I didn't want to take
these and she said don't
and I looked at her and just started
crying and I was like I'm so [ __ ]
tired I'm so [ __ ] tired of trying so
hard and she's like you're not broken
like you're you're not broken
you're fine your body knows what to do
you are fine you operate just fine like
relax Let It Go and so there's that
spiritual psychological perspective of
focusing so hard on what's not right
that you keep getting more of it and so
I just kind of quit a lot of things I
told Mindy Pals has been my doctor all
year basically and
um or most of the year and she's been
wonderful and I just told her like I'm
tired like I need a break and she's like
okay we'll take a month I'm like I'm
thinking like the rest of the year so
um so we went into a really minimalistic
protocol where it was like I'd only do
like three things three things because I
was doing castor oil packs at night
coffee enemas in the morning red light
um uh pocket machine a lymphatic
drainage massages body work with lymph
with lymph movement I've tried
everything like it was just my daily
protocols on top of all the pills was
just extreme and I was exhausted and so
I've just simplified it so I simplified
it to a couple of things I simplified it
to uh Dr Ayman has a supplement called
happy saffron that has like 25 plus
um studies already on it of the positive
effect so for just mood and mood
generally
um so I've been taking that
getting in the hyperbaric chamber
because that one is my least favorite
because it's so boring but um but I do
that for one to two hours at a time when
I can the other one which is EMDR now
let me tell you about EMDR I think I
feel like it's going to get there in the
questions I think somebody asked
something that I thought oh this is
where EMDR will come in but I'll just
quickly preface it
highly recommended by Dr Raymond as well
and also my I mean for me I had tried
this with my therapist yes I have a
therapist I actually plan to almost
always have a therapist I don't think
there's going to be a point in time in
life where I just won't maybe for a
couple months at a time here and there
six months but I always plan to have a
therapist because the work should always
be on yourself like you can't change
someone else you can only change
yourself so that's my word of wisdom
with therapy and we did EMDR and it was
like time travel
time travel there's also another book
called I'm look I'm pointing because my
bookshelf is over there the body keeps
the score and it's a super heady book
and it's like got a lot of dense
information but one of the prevailing
therapies for peeling everything from
PTSD to depression and all kinds of
different
um emotional states is EMDR because it
is like time travel and when I heard
EMDR for the first time I thought what's
EMDR do you is this like a do you take
something is it like you hook up to
something it sounds intense right but
it's it's not actually all it is and
every therapist has a different way of
doing it so some kind of use their
finger and it stands for rapid eye
movement rapid eye movement something
desensitization so you're basically
bypassing your normal way of thinking
and being able to access your memories
in a new at this point in time instead
of in your old patterning
um so my my therapist uses buzzers and
they're just little vibrators
one in each hand and it just alternates
it goes
and you think of sort of like a trauma
that's happened something that
emotionally marks you like it's not like
when you got in that car crash although
that might be one of them
um it's what has happened in your life
that you have a vivid memory of that you
um had an emotional reaction to or that
you know kind of pops up in your in your
reality now as a as a memory or maybe
like the backtracking source of why you
feel the way you feel
um I had one akashic reader tell me like
go to the first and the worst meaning
what was the first time and the worst
time that you had an emotion come
through going to those first and worst
going to those deeply emotional
traumatic moments your mind just wanders
and you can't if you get your head in
the way it's totally not going to work
quite right you have to like allow you
have to stop thinking you have to just
let things come through and if nothing
comes through fine but I promise you
once as soon as you not mentally think
I'll just not think but feel like I'm
just gonna surrender and sit here and if
we just don't have a good session today
fine that's when it comes through and it
is like re you're watching a past memory
from you're watching it as an observer
of your of yourself and you're also
watching the other person or the other
like whoever else is within the
situation
um and you not only see that but
sometimes I've seen
um how that person became like they did
or I've also seen Soul orchestration
where it's like I was aware that I
needed the experience that was difficult
to get me to where I went to give me
like uh uh to to stress me to to
challenge me to to give me some sort of
um an experience so that I knew how to
navigate something else more important
in the future I saw this like I like
literally like there is like a
controlling Consciousness or energies or
Angels or guides that are literally like
turning your head to look at a certain
thing happening so that you see it so
that you hear it so you can have the
experience so anyway EMDR really gives
you just this whole whole whole new
experience of an event that was really
traumatic and you go in and then you you
watch it's almost there's very much
um and this I'll say this later but like
in Michael singer's work with untethered
Soul it's about allowing things it's
about allowing an experience and
something that you something that's
going on to sort of go through you and
that ends up feeling like what you
really do is you you're watching it from
a wiser older perspective and you're
just witnessing it and you see it for
what it really is instead of what it
felt like then when you didn't have the
tools to navigate it better
and I'm just telling you it is I would
recommend everyone in the whole wide
world to do EMDR I think it is the best
thing ever so Dr Ayman said make a list
of your top 10 traumas and just go in
and start knocking them out so
um so those are the things happy saffron
Hyperbaric and EMDR have been sort of my
protocols for this sort of last quarter
of the year on top of that I will say I
did get my sauna and my cold plunge so I
have been using those but I only use
them when I want to like that's a rule
like if it doesn't we came up with this
sort of way of saying it
um we it's called the inside Lane
because like in racing if you go to the
outside it's just the hard way doesn't
mean you can't do it but if you go to
the inside it's the shorter distance it
tends to be the easier pass
um so it's like what is all inside Lane
stuff for me like what feels good and
easy if it if it's exciting if I think
it's like I think therapy is fun to be
honest or you know whatever it is or
jumping in the cold plunge for that like
shock and that experience like if I want
to do it fine you can do those things
um but it's got to be like inside Lane
uh like feeling things so
to recap basically
um it's been a journey it's very up and
down but I've since in the last sort of
three four months really just felt like
last three months that less is more
um I also am working out less so I'm
really only like lifting weights so
three days a week and every other day
basically it's just walking so I've like
toned everything down and honestly it
feels really good and I and I think that
things are really shifting at least I
feel better and at the end of the day
perception is reality so that's kind of
the health update I'll keep you guys
posted I still care about biomarkers so
um Dr Powell's Mindy and I have talked
about you know what are those biomarkers
so I'm still going to keep tabs on mold
metals and the hormones and thyroids so
um we'll keep an eye on those and just
um I'll keep you guys posted how it goes
all right I'll try and Buzz through as
many of these as I can okay would I
rather be 50 or 15 for the rest of my
life uh I'd rather be 50 for the rest of
my life for sure 15 was like well number
one I can't drive and number two and
three and four and five like you just
aren't that wise
um and uh don't have a lot of resources
so I'd much rather be 50 for the rest of
my life
um a burning man recap was requested
what do they need to know well
um Burning Man is uh like the hours are
different you know you kind of uh stay
up till you know the Sun or you know
somewhere between three four five six
seven a.m and um you know you don't get
as much sleep sleep a little bit I'm not
a big sleeper especially during the day
um and then you know it's just kind of
like riding your bike around so I'd say
you know it's like a different schedule
a lot of house music I didn't really
know that either
if you're a country fan you ain't gonna
find any you know Kenny Chesney out
there Jason Aldean it's gonna be uh it's
going to be all house and beats and
music so
um be into that what I loved so much is
it's just like people in their truth you
know if they want to ride their bike all
day and go to Temple and cry fine if
they want to party literally all day you
can do that too uh but I'd say you know
go in with an open mind um go with some
friends so you have some people to go do
things with and um make sure you bring a
lot of twinkling lights because there's
a lot of riding your bike around at
night and with 80 000 people there and
everybody having a bike they all look
the same and you're gonna need lights so
you don't get driven over as well
um and uh have fun with the costumes but
I think it's such a great experience I
mean I think that it's just something
that if you have any level of curiosity
it's totally worth going at least once
most surprising interview of 2022 so
Josh Gates kind of surprised me I just
ended up having a lot of fun with him we
kind of bantered back and forth he's
he's really like a modern day in Indiana
Jones so
um or actually not even modern day
because Indiana Jones isn't real he's
like a real Indiana Jones uh so that was
a super fun we talked we talked about a
lot of topics that I love to talk about
whether it be like travel or plant
medicine or any of those kinds of things
spiritual perspectives
um so that was great and then I thought
the other one that was surprising was I
loved the second so it's the second time
I've interviewed him but Dave asprey
um who's the like I can't even call him
The Godfather he's just literally the
father of biohacking he named it
biohacking because he came from the tech
World
um but Dave totally like normally it's
like a much more Health oriented tips
and tricks and big words that I don't
understand but we talked a lot about
spirituality and a lot about energy and
how this reality is working and um so I
thought that that second Dave asprey
interview was really cool I really
enjoyed that most inspiring interviews
of 2022. I'd say Zach Bush he's also the
second time I've interviewed him as well
I guess this is what happens when you've
had a show for a couple well three years
almost um so uh Zach is just like so
deep and again kind of similar to Dave
it was a lot more Health oriented when
when I interviewed him in 2019 about you
know cancer and how that works and you
know just a lot of different aspects of
pure heart more hardcore health and this
time it got more spiritual and it got
much deeper into how things really work
in the world and you know much more
about is there a theme here like more
about energy and more about your mind
and your perception and um I just uh I
just I love that that information is
coming through because it's uh it'll
change the world so anyway zax was a
great interview and then I think the
other one that was super inspiring was
Michael Singer I mean I was just so
grateful that he did it he doesn't do
very many interviews he wrote the book
untethered Soul such great information
to some degree kind of simple with the
information like meaning it shouldn't be
complicated to understand but just
really powerful and just like just a
really really really great guy so
um I thought that he he was very
inspiring as well okay uh my focus for
the next few years I'm gonna put a big
focus on business I you know I I
obviously worked and raced but then
after that I kind of have just like let
my creativity and my interests build
turn into businesses
but I'm not like the best boss like I
don't know exactly you know how to do
that I don't know numbers I'm terrible
like I I don't I'm not very good with
details so I just want to understand
better how to be a boss how to run
businesses how to make them more
successful
um so I'm gonna put a lot of focus in
the next few years into business and um
and also being out there a little bit
more I'm ready to do like another push
of um whatever I can do to help people's
confidence awareness and
um growth expand at the fastest and best
rate possible uh so I'm gonna I'm gonna
kind of jump in and see what else we can
so we could also see what else I can do
um so business is my focus for the next
few years
uh aspects of driver mentality that sort
of play that play into the spiritual and
personal growth side of things so
um I mean aspects of being a driver
include needing to be focused mind over
matter is also I mean to be in control
you need to know you can you need to go
into the corner with confidence and so
um I think that that plays into other
things too is having the confidence that
whatever's coming through energetically
or intuitively is true and that you can
trust that and you trust yourself I
think that that's an important driver
aspect that plays into spirituality
believing believing as a driver that
it's possible for you to go out there
and win and be successful just as much
as that there are
energies beyond our awareness
um or our consistent awareness for some
that are playing into our deeply into
our reality of how we experience this
life so
um having trust and believing is also
important places I'd like to visit oh
gosh this is like I could go on and on
um I'd love to go to Iceland I'd love to
go to
Patagonia Argentina Chile
um Bali Easter Island would be cool to
see
I'd like to go back to Egypt I'd also
like to see Petra which is nearby I
think Italy can you believe I haven't
really I don't think I've been to Italy
I've looked at it from Monaco before but
I haven't been there I'd like to go to
Italy I'd like to go to Spain and
Portugal as well and I'd like to go wine
tasting in France I think it's about
time I mean I've been to France with my
Danica Rose I went to Provence but we
were kind of working so it wasn't like a
trip trip
um so I'd like to go wine tasting in
France
okay I think that should keep me busy
for a while
um on top of that it's ski season so I'd
like to go skiing
um I just it's a new hobby
uh okay
what am I what am I interested in well
this is kind of a big question but it
also is a good explanation for someone
that might be new and listening and
curious about the show
um my interests are what shows up in the
show it's truly my selfish interests
most of the time that are what drives
the guests and the questions
so I mean I love spirituality obviously
I love Consciousness I love
um uh quantum physics the nature of
reality astrophysics
um so planets and universe solar systems
galaxies universes multiverses whatever
it ends up being
I like I like psychology did I say that
I really enjoy learning about how the
psyche works and how interpersonal
relationships work and how you can know
about more about yourself through other
people
um
I love psychology
[Music]
travel I don't do a lot of travel shows
but I do love traveling and um I just
love philosophizing so philosophers deep
thinkers
um those are kind of my hobbies and
interests and that is what shows up in
the show and unique unique and
interesting people you know just anybody
with a anybody that's had a really
unique experience is also really
um fun to talk to but usually it plays
into the realm of one of those things
that I've mentioned oh aliens too how
could I forget anybody that wants to
talk about aliens and extraterrestrials
and even when you don't still gonna
probably ask them about it
okay do you believe in time travel well
that's a right on time question based on
what I just finished do I believe in
time travel oh this is where my EMDR was
going to play in okay so I believe in
time travel uh
uh in a way that doesn't maybe seem as
obvious as like a good in this machine
and then I all of a sudden end up in you
know
2056 or you know back in you know 3000
BC
um
I mean EMDR is truly a powerful tool
um so I I mean do I believe in time
travel yeah I also believe it from a
from a more
quantum physics perspective a more
esoteric transcendental experience where
you know time space reality collapses
and doesn't have the same
structure and fabric as it does here
um that feels like time travel where you
can have an experience where you get a
lot of information and it might have
been a blink of an eye but the
information is not possible to digest in
a blink of an eye and um so I think that
you go to other places and spaces that
um are not this time space reality so
yeah
and and maybe in more unique ways than
riding on the ship I do believe time
travel is real okay how did I get into
the wine business uh well that's easy I
like drinking it it's true I just like
drinking it um anybody that knows me
knows that I pretty much just drink wine
every now and again I'll have tequila
um maybe vodka but pretty much just wine
and um so it really became something
that I just like was standing on a Knoll
in the middle of Napa Valley one day in
2006 and I was like in my mind I thought
it'd be really cool to have something
like this someday
and then it came true so your thoughts
become things at least they can so you
know I'm gonna go all cheesy dare to
dream like let your mind wander and the
things that you want to do in life where
you want to have or
places you want to go
companies you might want to start
um just start imagining them and um
yeah I'm not going to get too deep on
you guys but just know that thoughts
become things how to overcome
procrastination
I picked this question because I'm a
procrastinator but the one thing that
helps me to get [ __ ] done is I write a
list so that's my only trick that's my
only tip is just write it down write it
down what you need to do and then
naturally I feel like we all just
gravitate gravitate towards wanting to
cross things off a list so write it down
okay
um my view on Heaven and Hell and are
they real
um well I just got off of a great
conversation with Anita uh morejani who
had a near-death experience and she was
talking about having a house so it's
front of mine right now
um but truly my perspective is that it's
right here and that's what she said too
like you you decide it's your
decision
whether or not you just you want to
think positive thoughts and think
or think about negative thoughts you
want to live in fear you want to live in
love do you want to be positive or do
you want to be negative and it's within
that frame work that you are living in
heaven or hell and I think that one of
the things that keeps us stuck is Karma
and hell because it's not Karma isn't
like you did that so you're going to get
it back to you it's like no that's your
pattern you cheat people so you get
cheated like that's your it's current
it's just a loop of patterning and so um
so that hell is living in those negative
thoughts and like oh I never get what I
deserve and then you don't you don't get
anything that you deserve because that's
the way you think so I also think
Karma's kind of wrapped up in hell as
being um something that is uh keeps you
there so
breaking those karmic patterns
um or breaking patterns helps you get
out of that and um yeah
having help right here you pick life is
hard for sure but
re-patterning the way that you think
when things get difficult
is the journey
one part of the journey
okay something I learned about myself
this year
[Music]
I finally realized
how
I do everything fast
stupid I know you're like Danica you
drove 240 miles an hour like how do you
not think you do things fast but I
realize I do everything fast I cook fast
I walk fast I talk fast I think fast I
move fast like you name it I do it fast
and um
it hurts me sometimes
but it's also just kind of part of me so
I do think that I I have a fast thinking
mind and I I I'm very rational as well
so I'm not just like I'm not a lot of
times not really spiraling out of
control I'm just
dreaming things into reality and I just
like when my mind wanders and when I get
going I just kind of get going so I move
I think I do everything really fast so
that was something I learned about
myself this year so it's good to know
because there are times where it holds
me it is a is not the best way to do it
so it's good to know that about myself
now
what cars do I have okay I picked this
question because I just bought a new car
I still have my car I still have my
Range Rover right now and I've had it
for five years I mean it's a great car
it's beautiful it serves me it served me
so well it's like moved so many things
all over the place because I actually
got the long version so it's like a
Rolls-Royce in the back for the dogs
basically and my
um groceries uh but uh I'm ready for a
new one so I saw um I saw some I saw
Townsend Bell and I saw a guy that works
um uh very closely with Roger Penske
named Bud Denker and um I saw them on
pit Lane at the last NASCAR race of the
season in Phoenix and uh they we started
talking about cars and I was like yeah
I'm kind of curious about the new
Lamborghini Urus well it's not new but
it's a few years old
um I'm like I think I'm time for a new
car and Townsend said get the so Marco
Andretti told me to get the Audi
and I was like okay he's like it's
cheaper it's the same car same company
and then Townsend said
you know
you should get that Lamborghini because
the resale will stay way better it'll be
and it's a Lamborghini and I was like
you're right so done so I went and I
bought it so it's black on black on
black has like red wheels and red seat
belts but everything else is black with
carbon fiber on the inside I'm pretty
stoked to get it so any changes
spiritually that have helped the thing
that I have started to do
on a completely regular basis daily
I really trust my very nuanced
polls
like meaning like oh you should go do
this or oh you should go do that like oh
should I literally turn the corner to
the right or the left when I'm walking
my dogs and I'm just like
I kind of let other things like oh the
dogs want to go that way I'll go that
way
um I I I'm actually something silly I
just started doing
like when I picture like I have to put a
shirt on yes I have sweatpants on but
every time I get ready to do the show
now I literally picture myself in what
I'm wearing like as if I'm time
traveling to the Future to see what I'm
wearing and then I just pick the color
that I see myself in
that's funny I know y'all are gonna
think I'm crazy
um but I'm just like trying really hard
to live very very very true to in to my
intuition
I I learned this little lesson a long
long time ago in a grocery store
many times in a grocery store where I
would it always seemed like the place
would show up for me where I'd be
pushing the shopping cart and I'd be
like going around and all of a sudden I
just kind of like I'm wandering and then
I just turned one down an aisle I don't
even know why I turned down the aisle
and then I'm like oh yeah that's because
I need that and that happens so many
times to me that I was like man there is
like a a really quiet energy
like lying underneath things that if I
just listen to the tiniest little voice
that's sort of or or just let my body
move like all of a sudden I'll just
figure out what I I'll be in the right
place I'll get that thing that I forgot
to put on the list or I forgot to put in
my cart and that kind of is just sort of
like rippled out into more of a macro
with everything in life where I just try
and be really and try and live in the
intuition and um and also check in with
my body like
um
like feel where things feel how my body
feels meaning like when someone says a
truth my body gets a wave of Goosebumps
just like a quick wave of it and I'm
like okay or if something is going on
and I can feel like a knot in my stomach
I'm like okay this is like there's a
tense resistance or like if I can feel
my heart opening up or if I can feel
relaxed like just trying to tune into my
body to let my body give me information
because it's always giving you
information I mean sickness is giving
you information so trying to just stay
really close to like the very subtle the
very very subtle things that happen that
um are trying to lead you in the right
direction
psychedelic experiences well why not
right why not ask answer a question
about that I've talked about a few times
I've done lots of different psychedelics
the big ones for psychedelics would be
um psilocybin mushrooms and Ayahuasca
number one It's gotta call you
like it's got to come from inside of you
this curiosity something that you want
to do it shouldn't be someone telling
you you need to do this you have to do
this I mean someone might share that
that it was awesome but it's you've got
to be really Sovereign in your decision
to whether or not you want to do it but
a lot of times asking the question and
being curious is the start of it it
might not be a time but it sometimes can
be the start of it
um so it's got to call you and then the
second thing to know is that just be
ready for it to change your life it's
not going to be bad it's going to be
good but sometimes it's hard to get to
the good meaning you go in and your
reality matches your your external
reality matches your internal reality
like you're getting what you feel do you
deserve you're getting you're getting
how you're feeling like the people that
show up in your life mirror your energy
and the way that you act and the way
that you feel and then when you go into
these ceremonies you go into these
experiences you see things you've never
are seen before you feel things you've
never felt before and you then what I
would like to say I call just like
jumping timelines you just your internal
reality Now does not match your external
reality and so there's a time that it
takes to get that to match up and your
internal isn't going to change because
you can't unsee what you saw you can't
unfeel what you felt and so sometimes
that means relationships and sometimes
that means jobs and sometimes you move
all kinds of things can happen and so
just know that again it's all leading
you in the right direction towards more
truth and who you really are and what
you're really here for I believe that
and what's going on in this game of life
but there will be undoubtedly things
that will change so be ready for that
but no it's all for the good so that's
it gotta call you you gotta be ready for
Change and if you are then make sure you
find her like just word of mouth is how
you do it you just you don't go on the
internet and find like oh or am I gonna
go for a you know cool ayahuasca
ceremony you want that to be word of
mouth and let let yourself take some
time to find the right situation for
yourself what are my weaknesses uh my
weaknesses I am not very good at details
I am a little bit of a procrastinator as
I said earlier I'm terrible with numbers
like when it comes to
P L's taxes obviously I don't have to do
my taxes but uh Financial reports like
all that kind of stuff I mean
does not compute gotta talk to tech
support something something's missing
because math is not my thing I'm not
very good at being soft with the truth
not because I'm trying to be hard with
the truth but because I don't see it as
being hard meaning I just see it really
simple like uh
in a lot of situations truth feels very
obvious to me I don't like bullshitting
like there's many many times that
someone will be talking and I'm like
what's the point like get to the point
like why do we need all these words if
an email comes through that's longer
than a paragraph and I mean a short
paragraph I just don't read it because
it's too many words and like Haley who's
been with me for 15 17 years whatever
it's been now Haley knows like too many
words don't send too many words to me um
it gets confusing so uh yeah so those
are some of my weaknesses
um I'm sure there's so many more and I'm
sure that the people around me could
like help me out with what my weaknesses
are but I know those to be very true
um so and I'm very much a deep diver I
think that um sometimes that's a
weakness or I just like it almost seems
like I'm obsessed with something but I
just have to
figure it out like I go all the way to
knowing the truth which I think is a lot
of times why I move really fast is
because I'm just like let's just cut to
the chase I guess it's gonna work isn't
not going to work like is this business
the right business or not is that like I
just go go go go
um to get to the truth which ends up
coming through usually uh next big
project
um just a quick moment on it like I'm
actually I really like to develop a show
um I'd really like to develop a show
that talks about health you know that
gets into the into Health gets into
honestly specifically there's so many
times people want me to do stuff around
women
um being a female athlete but there's
not really much about the women's side
of things that I want to really like
talk about but when it comes to health
and hormones that is something that I've
had experience with and something that I
feel like I could speak to so uh
thoughts on the direction of the country
and the woke movement sometimes I read
these things I'm like I wrote that to to
ask okay okay okay thoughts on the
direction of the country and woke
movement
um okay so when I wrote this down what
came to mind first was that I this is
only how I work
I don't really participate meaning like
I don't really get into movements I
don't really get into like
ideological sort of arguments I don't I
just don't get into them I don't get
into the I'm like woke is like the
negative side of just being yourself and
um I don't think you have to like talk
about it you just do it just live it
like it's just to be lived and so the
more we talk about the things that we
don't want to have meaning
um you know biases racism you name the
you name the challenge in this on the
planet
just live with integrity and um that's
what I choose to do and I think that
it's also not in my wheelhouse like I'm
just this is not my comfort zone it's
not what feels natural to me so I there
are other people it feels very natural
and they feel very called to it's not
for me I just just have this perspective
that I just would rather kind of live
the way I want to live and let that be
my voice than have to actually go out
there and say let's not live like this I
just say let's live like this it's kind
of a reframe but that's how I view it I
just I don't watch the news anymore I
don't care about politics like honestly
I don't I just don't care I don't vote I
probably never will
um because and I don't complain either
like I have preferences I suppose but I
don't complain about it's not like oh
wow this country is [ __ ] because of this
um no like if I want to have a say so
and complain I have to vote and I just
don't I just don't care I just don't
think it makes that much of a difference
I think the real difference is in the
collective it's in our own Integrity in
our own autonomy to be able to just have
have
um be able to
properly make decisions in life and have
discernment for what's right and wrong
that's where I think the real growth
comes it's not through advocating for
the things that we don't want it's just
living the way that we do want
um yeah okay and then the last one the
best lesson of 2022 uh okay I think
staying in intuition and going with the
gut like how many times is it wrong you
have to listen to what your gut says it
doesn't mean you don't ride things out a
little bit it doesn't mean you kind of
like go through processes but you know
don't separate from that and I think on
like a sister to that is your inner
child I found a lot of value in
um looking at situations like from an
inner child perspective like would I do
that to my inner child would I do that
to my daughter
um would I put up with that is that the
right thing I think is an another way to
kind of access good decisions
because we have a hard time sometimes
making them for my for your for
ourselves me included so um so I think
that's a good little little like side
door to
um living with that intuition staying
true to yourself
living in integrity
playing the long game you know like
there's a lot of shortcuts to life to
just trying to get ahead or feeling good
for the moment
there's always a payoff you know whether
it's regret or shame or
um cleaning up some mess that you made
um whatever it may be there's there's a
payoff
um Integrity Trust
so play the long game and live in
integrity and trust your intuition and
uh
I think that leads to well hopefully a
pretty good 2023. thanks everybody for
listening to the pretty intense podcast
today I hope you enjoyed it if you like
what you heard today and you want to
hear more please click on the Subscribe
button